- So I think that you guys do
have something in common though.
So it's based on these photos.
Let's just take a quick look.
Yep.
- Oh.
- Yep.
- Oh. There's, yeah.
Can you explain?
- That's, well, that's face paint.
That's someone else painting my face.
- But you did that work on them.
- Oh yes, I did.
Yeah. So I'm.
Yeah, my mom and I face painted together.
My mom was a junior high
home economics teacher.
- Oh wow.
- And just insatiably creative person.
And she shadowed a birthday party clown
and learned how to face paint.
And literally, no joke.
Two weeks later, she was like
we're starting a small business.
And we've got a booth
set up at this Fall Fair
that celebrates everything apple and pork.
And we're turning kids into butterflies.
- Everything apple and pork?
- Yeah, it's called the
Apple and Pork Festival.
- I wanna go to that.
- That sounds awesome.
- Where is this?
- Throw in some cider.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- Central Illinois.
They, you know, they do it there.
- Oh.
- When?
- Yeah, we're turning kids
into butterflies and tigers.
It was this huge success.
So then we fly to the international
face and body painting convention.
- I didn't even know that was a thing.
- In Florida.
- That's amazing.
- It's a thing.
- Wait a minute, what year?
Because I was at the
body painting convention,
maybe we met then.
(laughing)
- He was head to toe tiger.
- Yeah.
- Full on body.
- I can see it, I can see it.
Do you still paint?
- I do, I do
Well a couple of years ago,
I painted Conan O'Brien's face
as a surrealist cat giraffe.
- [Kelly] I love him.
- And he was really spooky.
- I remember that.
- You remember?
- 100% yeah, now it's all clicking.
- It's all clicking.
- That's how we met.
- I love that you both
though have clown history,
like and it some with clowns.
- Were we ever a clown though?
- I was never a clown, but I.
- Please don't call her a
clown, she was a face painter.
- I didn't earn clown.
You gotta earn clown.
- Oh my God, oh my God.
It's so different.
- Face painter.
- I was so wrong, so different.
- But so I've been I've
been experimenting,
since it's COVID time I
can't paint any faces.
- Yeah.
- Well, I can't paint your faces,
but I have this new thing.
I'm calling face paint from afar,
and I brought one for both of you.
- Oh you did?
- Oh wait.
- Yes please.
I wanna see.
- Okay. I wanna see, are we gonna see it?
- [Eric] Oh.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Eric] That's me in Paris.
- It's you on your own face.
- That's actually really rad.
What? I would frame that.
- You can.
- That is so cool.
- And then we have, I know
you're obsessed with sunflowers.
And so am I.
- I am. I want that, I want that.
- It's yours, that is amazing.
Wait, that you have a moon as well.
I have a tattoo of a moon.
- You do?
- I don't know if you
knew that, but I did, yes.
- I didn't know that.
- That is amazing what you do.
So you do this with people like online?
Is that what you're.
- I am now.
I mean, this is, I just decided.
- You just started a new business.
- I just decided right now.
I'm starting a new business.